talking about mental health and pursuing
happiness and putting happiness
here's a story right here 42 percent of
gen Z has been diagnosed with a mental
health condition this is kind of nuts
before I do that I want to actually play
a video that Mia did and have her weigh
in on this
beautiful mirror right here let's play
this video
it's muted
try it again
it's what might be on a production
I used to hate myself and now I consider
myself to be one of the most confident
people that I've ever met you guys
always ask me but how like tell us how
and I'm about to do that do you see this
makeup do you see this hair do you see
my nails do you see the way that I'm
dressed do you see the way that I
accessorize I do this every single day
even if I have nowhere to go back when I
was struggling with self-confidence uh
depression I was depressed like actually
and
um I noticed that I would only kind of
like myself a little bit more when I put
in a little bit of effort to the way
that I looked and I'm not saying just do
your makeup and you're gonna feel good
I'm saying baby the routine is gonna
make you feel good I wake up every
morning at six go for a walk then I do
my comprehensive skincare routine then I
do my shower routine then I do my makeup
and I'm ready to go by 8 30 in the
morning well by 8 30 in the morning I've
already done three things for myself
that no one else can do for me I
challenge you all to get ready every
single day for a month create a morning
routine and let me know how you feel at
the end of the month it's powerful are
you so that's awesome especially for a
female okay for a female I mean guys we
have got routines too whether it's
meditation yoga skin care whatever
working out doing your thing hey we need
some more motivational media
thoughts on this so when you see this
Nationwide survey thousand people
surveyed between 18 and 24 42 of gen Z
is diagnosed with a mental condition
insane main conditions being anxiety
depression ADHD and one in forward
diagnosed since covet meaning in the
last two and a half years so gen Z on
top of that spends four hours a day on
social media and 85 percent of gen Z are
worried about their future so how real
of a problem is this mail well I also
believe that since we have access to so
much information and
um gen Z is still trying to figure
themselves out at this point a lot of
these issues
maybe we're also prevalent in other
Generations but there wasn't that like
self-diagnosed uh culture that we have
now now I'm like why can't I sit still I
type it in WebMD comes up it either
tells me I'm dying or I have ADD
um so it's also like we have access to
so much information that we're just
trying to diagnose ourselves to almost
make an excuse I do have a mental health
issues myself as far as like I can't sit
still for extended periods of time I'm
like shaking my legs I'm trying I took
five minutes left
I know I'm just like I'm like breathe
let's we we do this but it's almost like
it's not a weakness at the end of the
day like yes I would consider myself
um a person who has been depressed and
didn't know how what to do uh but at the
end of the day like I did find my
purpose and that really helped me move
forward so it's almost it's very
interesting that this percentage aligns
with the percentage of people that are
just like I don't want to pick a job if
it's gonna compromise my happiness
because it's also people aren't pursuing
things that could give them purpose and
then there's also a direct correlation
to mental health problems so it's almost
where we talk a lot this generation is a
generation that is not afraid to share
their opinion but I think we need to be
more doers than just thinkers or
whatever so planers exactly doors over
complain doers over complainers if you
don't like something change it instead
of sending a tweet yeah well I'm
definitely sitting with some doers and
not complainers you know how they say
that comparison is the thief of Joy yeah
you ever heard about that I think a lot
of problem with social media is that
especially with Instagram people you see
with these lives and you're like man why
isn't that me but the reality is it
ain't all about that on social media
like filters fake stuff fake news it's
not exactly all that it's cracked up to
be so if you like that clip click right
here to watch another or if you want to
watch the entire saucecast click right
here
[Music]